a secant line intersects the graph of f
of x is equal to x squared plus five x
at two points with x coordinates three
and t where t
does not equal three
what is the slope of the secant line in
terms of t your answer must be fully
expanded and simplified and my apologies
ahead of time if i'm a little out of
breath i just try to do some exercises
in my office to get some blood moving
and i'm i think i'm still a little out
of breath
anyway
so we want to find the slope of the
secant line
and they essentially give us two points
in the secant line they tell us what x
is at each of those two points and then
if we know what an x is we're able to
figure out what f of x is at each of
those points so we can make a little
table here
we know x
and we know
f of x
so when x is equal to 3
what is f of x well it's going to be 3
squared
plus 5 times 3
well this is going to be 9
plus 15 which is 24.
so this is going to be
and when x is equal to t
what is f of t
well it is going to be t squared plus 5t
and so we have two points now that are
on this line this is a secant line it
intersects our function twice so it has
these two points on it and so we just
have to find our change in y between
these two points
change in y and our change in x change
in x and i'm assuming that y is equal to
f of x
so our slope
of our secant line is
change in y
over change in x
our change in y if we view this as our
end point the second one with the t's
and as our endpoint is going to be that
minus that so it's going to be t squared
plus 5t
minus
and then
in our denominator our ending x minus
our starting x is going to be t minus 3.
now they tell us our answer must be
fully expanded and simplified so maybe
there's a way to simplify this a little
bit let's see can i factor the top into
something that involves that involves a
t
minus 3.
all right so
in the numerator let's see negative 3
times positive 8 is negative 24 negative
3 plus positive 8 is 5. so we can
rewrite this as
t
plus 8
times
t
times t
minus three
and so we could say this is going to be
equal to if we cancel out the t minus
threes or we divide the numerator and
the denominator by t minus 3 it's going
to be equal to t
plus 8. now if we wanted to be really
strict mathematically strict
this expression isn't exactly the same
as our original expression right over
here what makes them different well
they're going to be true for all t's
except where t equals 3. this thing
right over here is defined at t equals 3
in fact when t equals 3 this expression
is equal to 11. but this thing up here
was not defined at t equals 3. so if you
wanted to be particular about it if you
want this expression to be the exact
same thing you would say you would say
t does not equal 3. now this can take
the same inputs as this one
right over
right over there but i guess they're
assuming where t does not equal three so
this this you could view this as maybe a
little bit redundant but this would be a
this is the slope of the secant line in
terms of t